I'm here with Aaron Harris a partner at
Y Combinator one of the best
accelerators around the world before
joining my committee Aaron was the
founder of Twitter spree an online
service that connected tutors and
students thank you for joining us my
pleasure Amir thanks for having me so
let's start with a personal question
how did you come up with the idea for
Tutorspree well it was actually
initially my co-founder Josh's idea he
had this thought that we were going to
build an online platform for people to
buy and sell their time and that kind of
lent itself to tutoring and the first
way he pitched it to me he's like okay
it's an online platform for people to
buy and sell time in anyway I said
that's a stupid idea because it's just
like it just sounded too broad in
general as we started thinking about it
the thing we realized was that tutoring
was kind of a perfect fit for what we
were talking about I had tutored in high
school and in college I had had tutors I
had a lot of friends who were
professional tutors and as we kind of
talked to them about this idea we
started uncovering these things that
they actually needed and that's what
influenced us to sort of I guess iterate
our way towards what Tutorspree became
over time do you think this is common
for every founder is do funders and why
committer this is how did do it it
should be isn't necessarily always
sometimes people come to us with ideas
that are kind of made-up we call them
sometimes solutions in search of
problems where people just have you know
this really interesting technical idea
that doesn't actually relate to any
problems but I think the best ideas tend
to come from problems that people of
themselves experience so and now I
actually think Tutorspree probably
wasn't the best idea we could have done
I wasn't a professional tutor and
neither were my co-founders so there
were things that we didn't quite
understand we also weren't parents which
was kind of our in the end our target
market we didn't have kids going to the
process so while we learned a lot
through customer conversations and
watching how people acted I think we
missed things so how do i commenter
companies come up with their idea I
don't think there's any one single way
that that founders come up come up with
the idea but there is a common thread
between the best of them which is that
people are solving problems that they
have problems that they really
understand
I think Dropbox is a great example of
this where drew got annoyed of carrying
files around on a USB stick it's crazy
you have one on your keys it's a crazy
way to carry files around in a world
where we have the internet and and cloud
storage now you know in 2005 six satis
2007 when he was starting this remember
this concept didn't exist when I first
got my gmail account I had you know the
Gmail beta in 2005 I used it as cloud
storage I just realized that I was
thinking like when was the first time I
use cloud storage I would send copies of
my thesis to myself right from my from
my Harvard address just so I had a copy
somewhere in case my computer crashed or
in case I needed to print it up that's
such a silly thing to do email is not
designed for that but that was the only
way to really do it so he said I'm gonna
go one step further and Dropbox was born
and what do you look in when you look at
applications to Y Combinator yeah what
do you look at in terms of ideas in
terms of like the idea the founder what
we want to accept yeah so our thinking I
guess is my thinking on this has changed
over time and I think the same is true
with my partners I think we used to say
that founders were the only thing that
mattered idea was important but mostly
as an uninformed founders a lot of other
people tell you it's all about the idea
I think all these things are probably
too clear-cut right it's not that black
and white I think you need both founders
and ideas because if you just take
founders who seem really great but they
don't have good ideas they're probably
not great founders because great
founders have ideas of what they're
gonna work on and if you take something
that just seems like a really great idea
and the founders don't seem great
they're probably not gonna be able to
execute so I wish I had a clean answer
but the truth is it's it's both and so
we're looking for founders who seem
really great and formidable and and the
truth is we're not looking necessarily
for the most intelligent founders
because that's actually not the thing
it's not pure horsepower it's not
intellectual horsepower it's are you
smart enough to get this done but more
importantly do you have the
determination and the drive to just go
through brick wall after brick wall to
do it because let's face it you're gonna
screw up again
again and even if you don't screw up
things aren't gonna work out the way you
wanted and if you can't go through that
you're in trouble
on the other hand if your idea is
something that has no chance of being a
large business it doesn't matter if
you're the most determined founder in
the world it's not going to go anywhere
right